Speaker 1: All right. So the big media
story over the last 48 hours was Wednesday
night's CNN town hall of the failed former
President Donald Trump. On yesterday's show,
we did an extensive review of what was
said. The audience's roll and reactions,
laughing and cheering at the most depraved,
anti-democratic and dishonest moments. Anchor
Kaitlan Collins is respectable attempt to do some
fact checking up against the unfortunate reality
that Trump mostly steamrolled right over her. Had
the crowd on his side for the lies and that the
environment in some total didn't really conform to
one where serious fact checking and pinning Trump
down could happen in part because of the crowd and
because of the format and so many other things.
So we then heard again on yesterday's show from
people in the media, Joe Scarborough and others,
members of the House and Senate. We heard from
all sorts of different people about the town
hall and we heard from voters as well. And in
a focus group that CNN did of Trump supporters,
they were not more impressed or less impressed by
Trump based on the town hall. It did nothing one
way or the other to influence their opinion of
Trump. And then the question becomes, well, what
about independent voters? What about Democrats?
What about non-Trump Republicans? And it's hard
to imagine that they were overly thrilled by what
took place. So now there is a media question.
What happens with CNN after this insane
town hall. We know that based on the new,
relatively new leadership of CNN by Chris Licht,
that there is a change of direction happening
that's already happened. The network has hired a
number of Republican former Republican officials
and so on to to be on the network. But Chris Licht
did tell Kara Swisher during an interview back in
November that CNN is not going to become the Trump
news Network. This was the current head of CNN,
Chris Licht, speaking with Kara Swisher.
Speaker 2: You ended up talking about him
for 8 hours a day. And we're not going
to do that. We're going to be very
clear and take everything on a case
by case basis about what level of
coverage it should be.
Speaker 3: So meaning
that it will not be quite hand-waving.
Speaker 2: We are not going to be a 24
seven Trump news network.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Is that what they are sticking to or is it not?
And to be clear, Trump is a former president
in the completely unprecedented situation where he
is under criminal indictment, was recently found
liable civilly for sexual assault and defamation,
tried to hang on to power despite having lost. On
and on and on all these different things. So it
makes sense that corporate media talks about the
guy. It makes sense. But the question is, what is
the sort of tone and tenor of that coverage? Is it
sycophantic? Is it what what exactly is it going
to be? Now, just as interestingly, in the 48 hours
since the Trump town hall, during which Chris
Licht defended what CNN did, there has been some,
I guess we could call it lite rebellion coming
from within. Within CNN, There's an interesting
article on Semaphore. America was served very well
by what we did last night. CNN chairman Defends
Town Hall. But there are others who are quoted
here. The view from CNN staff is that it may not
be particularly the best thing. And they point out
that they don't love the fact that the audience
was filled with Trump supporters. CNN's senior
media reporter Oliver Darcy wrote, It's hard to
see how America was served by the spectacle
of lies that aired on CNN Wednesday evening.
And Licht said, I absolutely, unequivocally
believe America was served well. So there's
a couple of different questions here. Question
one is what actually happens on CNN as far as
Trump coverage goes? Does it become friendlier
than maybe what we saw in 2016 and 2020? I don't
know. That's certainly one question. The other
aspect to this is what about disaffected Fox
News viewers? Because that's part of the timing
of this entire thing. Trump has increasingly
turned against Fox News over the last year. Now,
with the firing of Tucker Carlson, there is a
significant contingent of MAGA people who they may
be watching Fox News now reluctantly, or they may
have abandoned Fox News and they want a new home.
Does Chris Licht want to appeal to those people?
And does he want to try to make the new home
for those folks? CNN And can he do that in any
way that is even remotely responsible as far as
journalism is concerned? Or can you really only
appeal to those people by becoming overtly
sycophantic and brown nosing about Donald
Trump? A lot of questions in this segment. Not a
ton of answers. We simply have to wait and see.
But it's not looking particularly inspiring. I
think that's where we can leave it for today.